From the guy who came “Straight Outta Compton”
and ended up in “Are We There Yet?”
Comes the most popular black Friday besides
Black Friday
and Rebecca Black’s Friday
Friday.
Before the release of Ride Along,
lace up your Chucks for another mid-90's classic
you can’t stop quoting...
“Daaaaaaamn!”
“You got knocked the f*ck out!”
"My neck!
My back!
My neck and my back!"
“Bye Felicia."
that has no actual plot whatsoever...
"Anything else happening?"
"Nope"
Experience a movie without a single guy person
in the cast.
It’s kinda like a reverse Lord of the Rings.
Meet man-child Craig.
When he’s fired for stealing from work
And his friend Smokey gets caught
They’ll make things right by stealing money
this guy stole from someone else...
It’s kinda Robin Hood if he stole from the
poor and gave to a guy named “Big Worm”
"Sup Big Worm?"
Experience a film that’s like a Spike Lee
joint but with fewer morals
and more actual joints.
Prepare to learn more practical lessons, like:
Get high
"I'mma get you high today."
Fight dirty.
And don’t get Catfished.
"Oooooooh, what's up?"
"God d*mn!"
But most importantly...get high.
“Ain’t nothing wrong with smoking weed.”
"Put it in your mouth!"
Watch Ice Cube pave the way for Ludacris,
50 Cent, and LL Cool J as the first good rapper
to suck at acting.
"Anyway... what you doing up so early?"
And watch Chris Tucker in the role that launched
him into Rush Hour stardom..,
and post-Rush Hour obscurity.
Seriously what the hell happened to Chris
Tucker?
Get ready to laugh at a film that would be
super offensive if it were
written by a white guy,
Featuring:
Asian stereotypes!
Latino stereotypes!
And, of course, black stereotypes!
"I wanna eat some of them chitlin.
I love pig feet!"
You want some Kool-Aid?"
"Man you know I want some Kool-Aid!"
But you don’t have to be from the hood to
love Friday, because this comedy speaks the
universal language of toilet humor.
"Hey!
Smokey back here takin' a sh*t!"
"Take a look at that paper over there on the
counter."
So if you love weed,
90’s comebacks,
and slamming metal doors,
then thank God it’s Friday...
And not the terrible sequels.
Seriously, those are like, Madea bad...
"Hallelujah!
Thank God!"
"You gotta let me go, haha!"
Wait I take it back!
Noooooo!
Starring...
Tall Kevin Hart
Left Eye Lopes
Sabretooth
Crackhead Bob
Michael Clarke Ducnan?
Daaaaaaamn!
#2 Dad
and Ice Cubed.
Friday.
Yo, I love it when they gave an ice cube to
Ice Cube so you could watch Ice Cube pick
up Ice Cube’s ice cube.
Hey ScreenJunkies fans, before we’re bored
to death by award season, tell us what Oscar-winning
movie you’d like to see an Honest Trailer
of next.
And while you're at it, please subscribe.